Intro. Hey there, fellow farmers and
ecoenthists. Have you ever wondered how
our plowing methods impact the
environment? Today, we're digging deep
into eco-friendly plowing techniques.
We'll explore how to minimize our
environmental footprint while still
producing bountiful crops. So, grab your
work gloves and let's get our hands
dirty. Main content. Let's start by
comparing traditional plowing with
conservation methods.
Traditional plowing involves turning
over the soil completely. This can lead
to erosion and loss of valuable top
soil. Conservation plowing on the other
hand aims to disturb the soil as little
as possible. It helps maintain soil
structure and reduces
erosion. Now let's talk about no till
farming. No till means exactly what it
sounds like, no tilling of the soil.
Instead, farmers plant directly into the
previous crop's residue. This method has
several benefits. It reduces soil
erosion
significantly. It improves water
retention in the soil. It also helps
sequester carbon, fighting climate
change. However, no till farming does
have some challenges. Weed control can
be more difficult without tilling. Some
farmers find it requires more herbicide
use initially, but many report that over
time weed pressure
decreases. Next up is strip till
methods.
Strip till is a happy medium between
full tillillage and no till. In this
method, we only till narrow strips where
we'll plant our crops. The rest of the
field remains
undisturbed. This approach offers
several advantages. It provides a clean
seabed for planting. It allows the soil
to warm up faster in spring, yet it
still maintains most of the benefits of
no till between the rows.
To implement strip till, first decide on
your row spacing. Then use a strip till
implement to create tilled strips. These
strips are usually about 6 8 in wide.
Plant your crops directly into these
tilled strips. Let's move on to cover
crop
integration. Cover crops are plants
grown to cover the soil rather than for
harvest. They play a crucial role in
eco-friendly plowing systems.
Cover crops help prevent soil erosion
during off seasons. They add organic
matter to the soil when plowed under.
Some cover crops like legumes even add
nitrogen to the soil. Here's how to use
cover crops with plowing. After
harvesting your main crop, plant a cover
crop. Let it grow through the fall and
winter. In spring, you have two options.
You can plow the cover crop under before
planting. or if you're using no till,
you can't roll the cover crop flat and
plant directly into it. Lastly, let's
discuss soil health monitoring. Regular
soil testing is crucial for eco-friendly
plowing. It helps you understand your
soil's needs and how your practices are
affecting it. Soil tests can measure
nutrient levels, organic matter content,
pH level, soil structure to conduct soil
tests. Take samples from different parts
of your field. Mix these samples
together. Send them to a soil testing
lab for analysis. Use the results to
guide your fertilizer and lime
applications. Also, consider more
advanced tests like soil microbial
activity. These can give you a deeper
understanding of your soil's health.
Remember, healthy soil is the foundation
of sustainable farming. By monitoring
your soil, you can make informed
decisions about your plowing practices.
Outro. And there you have it, folks.
We've plowed through eco-friendly
plowing techniques. From no tilt to
cover crops, we've covered a lot of
ground. Remember, every farm is unique.
What works best will depend on your
specific
conditions. So, experiment with these
methods and see what works for you. If
you found this video helpful, please
give it a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe for more sustainable farming
tips. Share your own eco-friendly
plowing experiences in the comments
below. Until next time, happy farming
and take care of that soil.